I'm used to thinking of the TED audience
as a wonderful collection
of some of the most effective,
intelligent, intellectual, savvy,
worldly and innovative
people in the world.
And I think that's true.
However, I also have reason to believe
that many, if not most, of you
are actually tying your shoes incorrectly.
(Laughter)
Now I know that seems ludicrous.
I know that seems ludicrous.
And believe me, I lived the same sad life
until about three years ago.
And what happened to me
was I bought, what was for me,
a very expensive pair of shoes.
But those shoes came
with round nylon laces,
and I couldn't keep them tied.
So I went back to the store
and said to the owner,
"I love the shoes, but I hate the laces."
He took a look and said,
"Oh, you're tying them wrong."
Now up until that moment,
I would have thought that, by age 50,
one of the life skills
that I had really nailed
was tying my shoes.
(Laughter)
But not so -- let me demonstrate.
This is the way
that most of us
were taught to tie our shoes.
Now as it turns out -- thank you.
(Applause)
Wait, there's more.
As it turns out --
(Laughter)
there's a strong form
and a weak form of this knot,
and we were taught the weak form.
And here's how to tell.
If you pull the strands
at the base of the knot,
you will see that the bow
will orient itself
down the long axis of the shoe.
That's the weak form of the knot.
But not to worry.
If we start over
and simply go the other direction
around the bow,
we get this, the strong form of the knot.
And if you pull the cords under the knot,
you will see that the bow orients itself
along the transverse axis of the shoe.
This is a stronger knot.
It will come untied less often.
It will let you down less,
and not only that, it looks better.
We're going to do this one more time.
(Applause)
Start as usual --
go the other way around the loop.
This is a little hard for children,
but I think you can handle it.
Pull the knot.
There it is: the strong form
of the shoe knot.
Now, in keeping with today's theme,
I'd like to point out --
something you already know --
that sometimes a small advantage
someplace in life
can yield tremendous results
someplace else.
(Laughter)
Live long and prosper.
(Applause)